all right let's go to take uh one more
call let's talk to matt
in louisville matt
hey what before we get going is it
louisville or louisville
it's louisville louisville i'm from
texas no when somebody's not from the
area because they say louisville or
louisville
i'm from texas in tennessee i'm going
with louisville man
all right that's something matt from
wolves
go ahead brother yeah um so
i'm calling in because my wife and i
we've been married almost 10 years in
this october
this coming up october um
this is kind of before where she said
that i've just
been a very selfish person um
a lot of times like she'll come and tell
me that i've made her upset about
something
and my go-to emotion seems to just be
anger like i just get mad at her
or telling me that i messed up with
something
and that i didn't fix something the
right way
and like i guess i kind of get scared
like when she brings that to me because
i feel like i'm supposed to fix her
problems
even if it's not a problem between us
it's just an emotion that she's
had with someone else and she's coming
to me because i'm her husband i'm
supposed to be there to listen to her
and i just i don't know why but my go-to
emotion is anger
you just jumped issues on me so she you
you made it sound like one thing but
it's actually two
so she comes to you with challenges
about you first
and you respond with anger and then
separately so there's a period at the
end of that sentence then separately she
comes and talks
about other feelings she's having about
other issues she's having other people
and that makes you angry and frustrated
too because you know how to solve those
right yeah okay so let's deal with the
first one when she comes to you and says
she's got problems with you or she
doesn't like the way you've done
something
is she right ninety percent of the time
yeah
so why do you get angry i guess
because i try to be i'm a perfectionist
i try to make everything perfect
and when something doesn't go the way i
thought it should go
it angers me and if i'm
if i'm doing something and i thought i
did it correctly and it was great
but it upset her and then she comes and
tells me about it
that i think that's where the anger
comes from and i thought well in my head
it was perfect
and it was great but are you angry at
her or angry at you
i think ultimately i'm angry at myself
but i take it out on her
[Music]
and maybe i am angry at her too for a
little bit because she pointed it out
but i know that's how i grow and i
make improvements to myself when people
point those
criticisms out to me yeah so
dude here's the thing um dr chip dodd i
love the way he presents anger
uh he helped me reimagine anger all
anger is
is a cue that you care about something
it's a good
thing it is a directional arrow towards
something that you are passionate about
that you love or that you care about
that's what anger is right okay acting
immature
and acting like a six-year-old and
stomping your feet and yelling or
lashing out to somebody at somebody
who's trying to help you
is um like i said that's
acting like a baby acting like a child
and so
feeling angry having that well up inside
of you i tried my best and it wasn't
good enough or i tried my best and i
just did the wrong thing
man that's natural feeling that's good
treating your wife
with disrespect treating her without
dignity just because she's trying to
lean into you man that's not cool at the
end of the day
you're letting your feelings and your
emotions drive your car
instead of your thoughts and your
actions okay
and so the default setting you've got to
adjust to brother
is think about a car the front two tires
those are your thoughts your thinking
and your actions and so when she comes
in and says hey man
you did the dishes last night you put
them on the wrong spot we've talked
about this can you please put them in
the right spot
and the thought pops in your head oh
yeah well you
that's when you have a moment to stop
stop that thought and say nope
and then you can replace that thought
with you're right we've talked about
this and i was trying to do something
nice
um and i didn't do it right and i'm
gonna fix that and then your actions are
you can stand up and go fix it
or you can stand up and look her now and
say thank you for telling me that i was
an idiot
and let that be that but instead you're
letting the back two tires of your car
which is your physiology like the way
your body feels you get your heart gets
racing and your chest gets tight and you
flex your muscles and you're like what's
up
and your emotions right they rage you
just get angry angry
right right and so you have got to
practice
moving your letting the front two wheels
of your car drive brother
and then the other side of this man when
she comes to you with
hey this happened today this is a
feeling i had this is a frustration
why do you get angry about that when
she's trying to connect with you that
way
i don't know that's that's a really good
question and that's kind of like what
i'm trying to figure out is why
that upsets me i guess that's where like
my selfishness comes in
to where i'm just like well that
happened to you that didn't happen to me
but that sounds like really bad when i
hear it i've never actually
said that out loud and that doesn't make
me feel good
so i'm i'm laughing i'm laughing at you
not with you okay like
why would somebody that you're married
to for a decade of your life she's
basically another arm and leg for you
right
why does her thoughts and feelings annoy
you
i don't know it's a good question where
is that selfishness rooted in man
i guess maybe that i feel like
i don't i don't really know i don't want
to say this
um because she has i mean there's a
couple issues that we're
trying to deal with we actually just
started marriage counseling monday night
right and so we're kind of working
through that
but um i know when
something hasn't happened that
i need in our marriage it
makes those times when she comes to me
with her feelings
and i'm i'm kind of like acting selfish
so i'm like well
you didn't give me what i need so i'm
not going to give you what you need
so are you talking about sex she doesn't
perform like you wanted to or with the
regularity you want so you're going to
show her
right and where does that where does
that behavior usually start
i'll just cut to the chase it starts on
a playground
right you didn't pick me for your team
so i'm not gonna pick you for my team
again we are back to
back to my brother matt in louisville
acting like a four-year-old the beauty
is i will say this you've done a very
um admirable adult thing and you have
decided you're gonna go work on this
now she may be dragging you but the deal
is you're going here's what i want you
to promise
me and the entire world listening to
this podcast you got it
yep when you go to your next counseling
session
i want you to tell them i talked to some
yahoo on the radio some quack on a
podcast
and i said some things out loud that
made me realize i'm selfish
and i'm immature and i want to fix that
and my promise to you is there are ways
to fix that
you and your wife are in a wonky
dance right now where you have
shut off all environmental signals
for intimacy and for connection because
she's coming to you with her feelings
she's coming to you with her heart
and you are getting frustrated and
annoyed by that because she's
interrupting your game
or you're checking out golf stuff on a
website or whatever weird stuff you do
in louisville
and you're frustrated and so she has
no environmental um
signals saying that you want to be
connected you want to be intimate and
then you circle around and be like hey
i'm not getting enough sex
and so i'm going to show you and there's
nothing sexual about what's going on in
your house right now because
you're annoyed by her you're annoyed
when she shares her heart you're annoyed
when
she doesn't do exactly what you want and
it's just making this figure eight of
frustration
right and so at some point somebody's
gotta step
up and say i'm breaking the figure eight
i'm gonna stop it
and sexuality and intimacy and
volume that starts with a series of of
environmental offs and ons
not a series of my sex drives more than
yours that's a whole other conversation
that we can have another day
but i want you to start with your
therapist start with your marriage
counselor
i'm proud of you for going man walk in
that door and say hey listen i'm selfish
i'm immature i act like a child
the way i respond to you leaves no
no room for you to even think about
intimacy in here because i've not
created a safe and welcoming place
a place where you belong where your
feelings belong where i can listen to
you where i can just look at you and say
that sucks
i hate that somebody treated you like
that at work today
or man i didn't do the dishes right
again oh my gosh i'm so sorry i'm gonna
get it right i walked right past my
shoes
that i left on the front porch i didn't
fill your car up with gas
i'm sorry i'm gonna make that right and
not that little boy rage it's like oh
yeah well i'm taking my bag and going
home
that starts with you matt that starts
with you and i think you've got the
courage to do it
and i'm giving you a hard time because i
see some of that behavior in myself i
see that behavior in
millions of men all across the country
where we were
not taught we were not trained on how to
be in relationship we were taught how to
win
we were taught how to compete and we
were taught that being a boy meant
being over not with and i want you to
and take this time take this snapshot
you've been together a decade
you got decades ahead of you i want you
to take this time with a marriage
counselor and i want you to learn the
skills of connecting
learn the skills of shutting your mouth
and being with learn the skills of
when you feel that anger inside that
tells you you're not good
you didn't you failed you suck that you
go nope
i am a person of value she loves me and
i'm gonna go make this right because
she's worth it
so matt on irony man thank you for the
call thanks for reaching out
you